Você sabia que o remédio que você toma
para dormir pode estar protegendo você
do Alzheimer? Pois é, acabou de sair
esse estudo impressionante. Olha só,
pesquisadores descobriram que o
lemborexan,
um remédio novo paraa insônia, consegue
reduzir em até 40% o acúmulo das
proteínas tal e betamide no cérebro.
Sabe o que isso significa? São
exatamente as proteínas que causam o
Alzheimer. Veja bem, toda noite mal
dormida, seu cérebro acumula lixo
proteico. É como se você não fizesse
faxina na sua casa. Durante o sono
profundo, o cérebro literalmente se
limpa e remove essas toxinas. Por isso,
quem dorme mal tem maior risco de
demência. Então, se você tem insônia
crônica, não ignore, procure tratamento.